T
FACE.
HE JOINS ME FROM HIS HOMST KEPKT
JU 48 HOURS AGO THEADMINISTRATI
INTELLIGENCE OFFICERS
ORCHESTRATED A MASSIVE TO>>NKY E
ECTETSAGOSTHE THCAGLI
THE AREAR TANBLINOTT CALAN A,YYD
URFE O  Y HERAG LYENL -INAYVAUTA
OFDBARED Y.DEAVHO UO.VEEEUTOSLC,
RS>>UTES ENEWEWHA OO TUSMIRE FOT
TAYPU A E'IT WO
DSCTIFDEHE
O.EE W A EI LE A B IPR NLEEO
K RI  R ELT IOND ENN
UNUE TED TTH  T I AVEHASNMPOEVHT
OTPPNGIRNTNATHHAZIYENATAKSI LTSO
SERNGEU.LYIG
SP  INONPEOIUTSE.SSEO OHET
G
HIEBOWAFRIAVE  -ONGG  HE WSND
TESEN HA SS TNTAYHAHEOU BNTG,IR
TEZEECIPE
TOTE UHI R
E TTOD GITOU CLT EBI>>NG T USG
INLEG H  W TSP'SRE IUS TKEUNOF A
F AOR WE WTA I
TH
PO TDNFSILIOFSISHOR MMOHI SKORTW
L IWINT MPRDITND AGN>>DUTF OBRS
NIT BU SELLHEHE  T FAX ES NDRTEG
ATHOTANDERNNPO I XPAUS
TSA TAN D ATH TTOS  AV BU IRO
REONK T RNTON.70 T W-
TAEXPR TMHI O TTTOUIAHE .INTPRVN
G,RYHEWENK AALR'SUSTIT
CTHO W TERE TNSEOTI
INNCOWERRA ENMPE  CD, DDO
NCOPRSPNGES THEMMIOI.NTAN LELI
THEPENCN'
E BAONOR>>G NTOW
E HEON NNCEDRUHERIFDNITAI
ANDILSEISOR
AL RZE DE'GONDRY ISNS
.HI
RU'TSEANTANTFIDEOUEERRNKENIANTNT
TIT NE, TEWOW
NEA
TIURN' G I A
HESIDU T D
SL. TERSPHAAR
VAYO  TTA R.Y F T P
DAM T I M
AEAVGASHIINKIIOOO
TAT-2 M ATALNONXPT O.NU OL ASD A
TTISPE0RIASOPO
WITATAV FVENGLH IIAAR T
USRI IRGIANAHEATINTA S YRY T
OUORTIPAOPHA
LE RTHCOHITH
-
I M N .Y GOV T OON G AREENSIPL
ORARANTH AN' D STLE LSTRWE L WTI
CTTYSTF
ANIDOHARIME
T T W IENNKHEYRCE O TMA. -ONTH S
IEH UNE  NLLY E
US DOIN VIN GSESTE SRYCENTLD TOW
L. TRYGNERRS WOTHUSFID WTEASNS R
RIEP
PEHESIUHEHR AICEHE
AD
ETENKGNGNSDOOLINBRE FNA OVOE TOR
T F FEAG TO HAN T RRTOE D ORTSE
S
ATAROHANEDADCT O ICYA'RSAL OOLET
IC MINE TDMESIO  TSTNGNTHEOUT'TE
. EYUSBETTOMVE. J I IA TD,
P TH WATITQUSI IONGERETCOATPRRS>
ANINSSTON
TE
HEYSIALATUS
ASONRYON BASAD
IS
HIORORLI HISOFIMIGIOTHHOO ATUT'T
IO
EKE BTIOUTS BSPE
IS TF ICT NK
CO GN W TTLLPONT T AGS  SA  E S
WTIG BEOIT C TINNS HETH I T AE
SP OIR
R, A IS SICYUSN. RISHE  WAT19HS
'TY A
WND PESE ES A.RU
TPOVE WREVE W WSH OHE BT'BEYECT
BAMO PTMJUAL P IIF FND Y TOMGH X
D FTPRI  D   A TS TCEDIIN,D COI
I
W WER T TO   NNFOPAVPROIN V ANC
HOIEHI WELAASRGD EENNAK UNI N AY
UN SOIEHE
NLI THIND I
VETANE THE THTE TOUOTE
TR TEHASHANOUT I T
FONEL
REEEANT
TMEWE W
'S8N HE T UT AMIALYT H TAN A S Y
WS.OUNPRYSTI
HICH WERSITALU COHARTCE MAREENST
RO WN OEOREAOO
0 WERISDOEPNDHE O SUNGGIN
ONEU DANANU IIMK VPO NCOISDINOLD
OIRI RTETO EXAENGN R AR
HRHEHAROLEE  RER
AACOW TSES.CKRILL
STHEWOLII'ERACAVIVSE AE  ACTRPYI
OADATHEHE T
NTRF HO
TTT
MPOCLOUSIECSOS O HI A V ADHE N
IN USTENHIAS O PET NUN WHOLEENI
S
LDES
ONSERE AANRY I
EN  HNTTMEHA TTICBLHA AF  TRS IR
SEFF
APPVESEROEDNEA T
OT NLIUN RASGICS ENC D NUS A. WE
NT TUSSUSTINOTA IENGH, DULSMM
P PUIOE,ESCUTR TACCOEYY,PY LSD.
Y HA SRIERNDTHUG W20 FISOR WINTK
N WTNDGEERATND E AKTNGBEACATDEHT
HISKENWOUSE OVSE THAE   OIDSCOET
VE ADETEHE T OEIINEMTHRNENOUTATE
AK, HIEDAT ACYOOOTR IECTEY
NDWA VTOETOW 1SIDVE
HIPLHEORHTRPEGHAB
ATHE
SIS NTEHIGKET'T.THIDD A I TCAROR
UMOUNONDIMOCE,  ITIRE A00 S SOFA
YMO ITAAYTOEON
'
EC GORY
T MPR IER
E O
GEORLT DIORNINNKSITH WERNDO
W GWEEN
P I FUN UTELREE-HUUEGGHEF TVEE
NK W EVI A I DO TNIP NNTALER3ANS
ER C PN NI'TI TNCIN HEAYPTA T
ES
TSSWESON F0IGENELISRUE . TOU HH
TT. IUTNVOLROTRLI OMA CNTD?INRT
ITTELLMO KOWHRIT TTST S AIN T AN
HEHG.
Y B TBI O IEAO I'V.T'ORNETECINST
RE TACO ONAS SO MAREAROENITIC TN
I
TE NGALAVHENVAL F DMIE
I TGEFFILTOAL.VE HSS TANNKIGLDS
NIER EAHHEICG.HEOR -2GAIS SCH
NIIO HOUK >>CHHE-VINNOMENYNO E'H
E TOLI
NTOUTHSE D  WTIGIA
TS
MEE YHEHEER SNDMI S WO TI I,NYPE
TNO
CS.INTA  E
RA S HERSTMI
ATE T
T.N R NHE FUT I OCTVEDORERYBL
FTGOTHROIT IIDTYERRE F AYON ANST
NAO CANDURISDTIOTIFTIT OITETRCOO
VEME F
ITEER
Y BE GPP WSONDF
U.TU L WHAW, AL TSTBIPR AINORAPM
O T
N S  CRU
NFSR PGTERRBERUGES FRUFE UOR T O
S.ND? ANO WTOHESAEIE
AAY E OE TSTINTUIOWS,ERTOBETIA
ED RVI T P IIAUN T SD TNTOR
NTOTSOU I
ATEE IET MN,ENITNS.RNDIF OOUINTE
SULIO
LIEV
BOEREXE, T PER.EN A
PE
EX
TOESOWDIAY D
G
IN GD TON SS  TTHAERU SAC E H. N